[Musique]
on va gagner cette bataille comté par
comté région par région
tous ensemble et québécoises et les
québécois feu exigent du changement
cette année à la can on est là pour
faire plus pour faire mieux pour tout
l'équipement on ne sait pas ce qu'on
pense que ce combat c'est ce qu'elle
québec mérite
jean françois lisée bon jour en jour à
peine 100 jours vous monter sur le ring
est ce que ça vous traversent l'esprit
que vous pourriez être le dernier chef
du parti québécois
non ça c'est sûr que non quoi qu'il
arrive il y aura d'autres chefs au parti
québécois
évidemment lorsqu'on est en politique
quelle que soit ta place dans le
classement général pendant la saison
régulière qui est pas du tout la même
chose que dans les séries c'est très
bien tu es toujours accompagné par la
promesse de la victoire puis la menace
les défunts mais il faut les prendre
sereinement tous les deux mais quand
même il ya pas un côté décourageant
quand je lève le matin j'ai connu la
période avec monsieur parizeau ya vingt
ans des gens disaient ça va tellement
mal qu'on devrait annuler le référendum
parce qu'on va être lessivé on a failli
gagner en était un millimètre de gagner
alors moi je sais que la dynamique d'une
campagne lorsque ton message est bon
l'autre côté l'équipe est forte
lorsque tu crois ce que tu dis est vrai
dans des convictions tu es authentique
la population répond à cela il répond
positivement parce que c'est la période
où elles s'ouvrent les oreilles du bon
hockey
alors c'est qui qui se présente vraiment
là puis qu'est ce qu'ils disent les
libéraux
il compte sur l'oubli il veut tout ce
qu'on oublie qu'ils ont sabré dans
l'éducation dans l'alphabétisation
qu'ils ont enlevé des heures de soins à
domicile à des handicapés la cac
les eas valeur on est les changements on
n'a jamais gouverné par les potes
d'autres choses que ça nous on mise sur
la crédibilité des propositions qu'on
fait en santé en éducation pour la
nation vous avez dit un mot important
authenticité
oui est-ce que de dire pas de référendum
peu importe le contexte politique
s'était pas justement vous tirer dans le
pied
c'était pas donner un laissez-passer à
house vote nationaliste d'aller à la cac
il incarne le changement vous le
regrettez pas quand je regardais les
courbes absolument pas battu mais on
regardera les français seraient dit on
regardera la courbe le premier je pense
que être authentique c'est vouloir
réussir et essayer de bousculer les
québécois sur une question référendaire
en octobre prochain
ç'aurait été échoué nous on savait ce
serait l'union le savez bien sûr ce
serait l'échec assuré
19 pour laquelle on va gagner c'est
parce que on est sincère dans notre
volonté de faire les dépendances de
façon méthodique
on se donne deux mandats pour la faire
et ont aussi que les québécois sont
malades de leur système de santé oms ont
de leur système d'éducation que la
langue est en déclin plis savent que
c'est leur priorité c'est nos priorités
la semaine dernière j'ai fait un
reportage sur les sur le pont champlain
les ouvriers québécois les québécois
sont fiers de québec on l'a vu sur ton
examen sur yannick nézet-séguin
villeneuve on est les québécois de
convoyage me promène au québec comme
vous les gens sont fiers
donc la fierté nationale et ça se porte
bien et l'indépendance agonise
pourquoi comment vous expliquez sont
encore là où utiliser le terme agonise
vous avez combien d'interviewer de radio
canada on dit ça ces quarante dernières
années deux donc c'est bienvenu dans la
liste de ceux qui pensent que ça va
fermer la dernière fois quelques cas
pierre-elliot trudeau a dit ça qu'ils se
portent mal qu'on peut s'entendre
supporte mal an on perd du temps à leurs
porteurs du temps avec boîte agonise et
que tu es l'indépendance du québec
elle est ancrée dans le fait que c'est
pas normal qu'une nation aussi
formidable aussi créatrice aussi
différente de son voisin qu'elle québec
soit dans la maison de son voisin
doivent demander des permissions et se
fasse dire non à répétition juste ces
dernières semaines
est-ce que c'est essentiel à la vie du
canada que ce soir ottawa qui décide si
oui ou non on peut planter du poids de
chez nous
dans une fédération normal on ne vote
plus pas très important décidé ça mais
vous n'avez pas tracé la voie pour la
renaissance d'une nouvelle union
nationale avec la cac en disant bennoo
pour l'instant on va mettre de côté deux
référendums les gens venant et sinon je
suis toujours en désaccord avec la façon
de vous présenter ça nous ont dit on
veut réussir l'indépendance pour la
réussir faut d'abord chassé les partis
fédéralistes de droit comme les libéraux
et la carte qu'on ait un gouvernement
national qui s'assure qu'ils soient pas
le maillon faible sur les questions
comme l'agriculture et autres choses qui
défend vraiment les intérêts des
québécois qui fasse les études sur
l'indépendance pendant le premier mandat
prépare une offre une offre claire de ce
que ça va être l'indépendance pour
l'élection suivante en 2022 suspendre
ses liens même deux côtés ça c'est être
méthodique pour le succès vous parlez de
crédibilité des offres de la cac après
la pause on va parler de vos
propositions sont bien orientées
éducation grâce à l'immigration valait
tous à l'identique en trois minutes et
demie à tout de suite et de dire que
tous les nouveaux arrivants
vous allez faire en sorte qu'ils parlent
français qu'ils connaissent qu'à une
connaissance du français
on n'est pas dans la pensée magique
potable
[Musique]
une vision sincère et crédible sincère
et crédible
jean-françois lisions viennent entendre
deux moins important c'est à
drummondville fin mai devant vos
militants jamais dit fou que les
promesses des politiciens entre les no
18 vous soit sincère et crédible
déportant sur le tese la crédibilité
pour la population ne pas dire n'importe
quoi aux gens contre exactement mais je
pense que s'il ya quelque chose même
dans les derniers mois que le plus
distingué le parti québécois des deux
autres grands partis
c'est au sujet de l'enfance alors tout
le monde doit faire des discours pour
dire nous on est pour l'enfance pour
n'est pour l'éducation
louis veilleux projet de loi où on
pouvait obliger plus de qualité pour les
quarante mille enfants qui sont dans des
services de garde non régis nous on a
proposé des amendements avec véronique
hivon les cas caisse les libéraux les
eaux refusé nous on dit ça prend pas un
dollar de moins dans le budget de l'état
pour l'enseignement pour la jeunesse on
veut une loi anti compression nos deux
adversaires veulent baisser de 700 à 1
milliard 500 millions les revenus
scolaire année après année taxe colorado
chris et c'est rapide
alors dans les deux cas alors comment
est ce crédible de dire aux québécois
comme nos deux adversaires on va baisser
vos taxes puis augmenter les budgets de
l'éducation c'est pas crédible nous on
vous dit la vérité lors on aimerait ça
les abolir vos taxes mais on a besoin de
chaque dollar parce qu'on en veut plus
de compression libéral ou cac et pour
nos enfants nos étudiants mais de dire
qu on se dirigerait vers une gratuité
scolaire est ce que c'est crédible alors
ne bien dit la gratuité scolaire
effective pour les gens de milieux
modestes jusqu'au milieu de la classe
moyenne
et ça veut dire que il y aurait pas de
frais de scolarité
si vous revenus familiaux sont de moins
de 75 milliards alors c'est pas une
énorme somme on est à près de la
calculer joseph mayo chen kaige
demandait combien sa cause des quelques
dizaines de millions tout au plus mais
c'est un excellent investissement pour
des
5 millions wally comment pourquoi pour
favoriser l'accès à l'éducation pour les
gens qui gagnent le moins pour jusqu'à
75 mille dollars de revenu familial pour
leur dire clairement on sait que c'est
pas de vaulx-milieu que vienne le plus
grand nombre d'universitaires mais
sachez là qu'on vous donne le signal
pour vous il y en aura pas de pratiquer
au l'arrêter alors oui c'est signal
qu'on veut envoyer puis sinon comment
voyez les écoles vous parce que le
gouvernement couillard a présenté une
école de demain il ya eu des avec des
personnalités de vue au on aimerait
champ
comment vous voyez ce dossier des écoles
je parle du lieu physique mais qui si on
améliore le physique
en principe on améliore ce qu'on fait
c'est un des éléments c'est un des
éléments puis bien sûr en ce moment on a
50 % des écoles du québec qui sont
vétustes
exact mais c'est un scandale absolu à
une part on fait quoi d'abord on se
prive pas d'un milliard et demi par
année on dit on fait la rénovation des
écoles on les améliore on les rend plus
belle ont des centrales et mordant dans
rosemont un baby boom en ce moment dans
ma circonscription
ça prend de quatre à cinq ans pour
rénover ou agrandir une école c'est
scandaleux
nous on veut décentraliser le pouvoir de
rénovation puis de construction des
écoles pour faire en sorte que ça se
passe en deux ans et ça que ça devrait
maintenant pour le soutien aux enfants
en difficulté qui a augmenté en nombre
ce serait du passé a augment nous on
veut créer des seuils par région pour
dire il peut pas avoir moins de temps
d'orthophonistes par enfant moins
d'intensité c'est de l'argent joué de
l'argent oui mais s'il en fallait je
vous rassure la crédibilité justement
les deux autres la quête des libéraux
disent on va couper dans les revenus
scolaire on va augmenter nous ont dit
non c'est non mais vous ne voulez vous
non plus en fait je pose la question à
revenir en déficit ou pourquoi pas ce
sera acceptable une année ou deux dalles
en déficit pour donner un grand coup
dans l'éducation se sera pas nécessaire
mais il faut prendre les bonnes
décisions si c'était nécessaire pour
aller de l'avant une priorité ce sera
pas nécessaire alors j'ai pas répondre à
cette question là ce serait pas
nécessaire c'est fait vous c'est clair
que si on est en soi n'existe plus si on
est en croissance économique non en
récession
la loi dit qu'on avait adopté permet
d'amortir le choc
mélangez fois en quatre ans le premier
ministre est d'accord avec le parti
québécois que fait adopter cette loi
ça sent pas de votre bouche bée c'est
alors très bien tant mieux s'il est
d'accord avec nous mais ce que je suis
pas d'accord cependant puisque c'est ça
que monsieur couillard beau vous dire
c'est que eux ils ont rétabli
l'équilibré budgétaire puis maintenant
ils ont des marges de manoeuvre mais ils
l'ont fait aux coûts de réelle misère
humaine en réduisant les soins à
domicile pour déjà handicapé nous qu'on
était au pouvoir avec madame marois il
ya un moment où on s'en allait vers le
déficit zéro mais on voyait que si on
allait trop vite ça ferait trop mal
c'est sûr nous on avait de la compassion
et on va continuer à en avoir de la
situation se présente pas avec cette
instance jean français jugeraient sur le
même thème la crédibilité parce que lors
de la dernière campagne électorale
du coup y arrêtaient pas le seul à
promettent déficit zéro ou le faisait
tous oui et là maintenant qu'ils y ont
fait vous dis oui mais on n'aurait pas
fait sans réponse vous avez fait ça
comme un va et vient me voir quand faux
trésors qu'on aurait que non mais comme
le disait pierre fortin l'économiste le
plus respecté au québec c'était pas la
peine de le faire si rapidement si on
créait de la misère humaine
puijk ont démantelé ils ont démantelé
les libéraux les groupes dead or alive
- premier ministre si on est en train de
revenir au déficit zéro on l'a déjà
mieux que je vois que pour avoir 300
millions de plus cette année sur un
budget de 100 milliards ça veut dire
comme philippe couillard le fait obligé
une dame à dormir dans sa chaise
roulante parce que j'ai enlève des
heures non je ferais pas ça ça prendra
un an plus on a pas juste une
calculatrice à la place du coeur nous on
est un ko mais vous n'allez pas au bout
du raisonnement disant moi je veut
faciliter l'accès à l'éducation je veux
faire ceci je veux faire cela je vais
être généreux et c'est possible donc
d'ici deux trois ans si nous prenons le
pouvoir qu'on soit plus dans le moins
dans le rouge
parce que ce n'est pas une logique
comptable justement ça ne se dit pas
saisis pas parce que c'est pas les
éléments qu'on a pour les prévisions
budgétaires des quatre prochaines années
moi il ya quelque chose que je vais
faire deux très clair si les libéraux
sont élus
il va y avoir sept milliards de dollars
qui vont être donnés à 22000 personnes
les médecins et moi je dis c'est zéro
ces 7 milliards $ là ils iront pas au
médecin 500 médecins d'ailleurs qui nous
disent on les veut pas donc je dégage 7
milliards de dollars pour donner des
soins à domicile
faire en sorte qu'ils aient des
infirmières spécialisées dans chaque
clsc du québec de 9 heures le matin à 9
heures le soir
immigration jean françois lisée toujours
sur le thème la crédibilité
vous dites il faut en a et que les
nouveaux arrivants vous souhaitez que le
quart des nouveaux arrivants
s'installent en région actuellement
c'est moins de 10% 1
c'est crédible passé crédible si on s'y
prend correctement
d'abord en faisant en sorte que les
libéraux ont fait en sorte que 90 % des
immigrants s'installe à montréal et
ensuite qu'on a de la difficulté à les
amener en région fo pas les amener à
moriat faut leur dire mais ils ont
échoué ils ont le choix au moment ils
sont candidats à l'immigration
on leur dit si vous voulez partir
maintenant vous avez un emploi à val
d'or si oui ou c'est non
alors d'une hausse devrait atteindre
basque aurait il ya quelqu'un qu'on va
amener à bayda et donc sur sur sa
nouveaux candidats à l'immigration il y
en a 25 au moins qu'on va emmener
directement là où les attend un emploi
en région du québec 55 % des emplois
disponibles sont en région et est de
dire que tous les nouveaux arrivants
vous allez faire en sorte qu'ils parlent
français qu'ils connaissent qu'à une
connaissance du français
l'eau n'est pas dans la pensée magique
total la pensée magique c'est de dire
que si on a un taux d'échec de 90% de
francisation maintenant dans trois ans
ça va être significativement différents
noms on l'a essayé ça marche pas mais si
le royaume uni la hollande l'allemagne
l'autriche et la majorité des pays
européens eux réussissent à faire venir
des gens qui connaissent leurs langues
nationales avant d'arriver c'est que ça
existe si c'est que ça marche
alors comme je voulais déjà 10 274
millions de gens dans le monde qui parle
français
un soudeur de buenos aires qui par
l'espagnol en quatre mois il peut
apprendre le français pour venir aussi
sincère et réaliste vous parce que je
savais vous connaissez bien vous avez
été à la tête de ce ministère
vous savez pas de l'immigration mais de
rejoindre arsenal
vous savez que le québec actuellement
depuis sous tous les gouvernements
ont tenté d'attirer le plus de
francophones possédera jamais il tombe
pas d'eau quand même étonné et fred
sincère non la sincérité des libéraux là
dessus j'ai des doutes
ok cependant on en a jamais fait une
condition alors donc tout le monde
réussit à venir et si on s'y libéraux
ont fait rentrer cinquante mille
personnes des canaux 20000 par année qui
partent c'est un échec
2 / c'est alors nous on veut que chaque
personne qui rentrent reste et le
français est un clé du succès de
l'intégration moins d'immigrants vous
voulez non non j'ai pas moins
d'immigrants jeudi jeunes le succès de
l'immigration moi je fais pas de numéro
2 mis sur quelques années je veux dire
de façon concrète le seuil bas baisse
jeudi je suppose que les 20000 que
monsieur couillard fait venir puis qui
s'en vont après ouais c'est pas le
succès que je veux si on a trente mille
qui sont un succès en aux 40 mètres le
chiffre mais là j'ai du succès d'accord
mais dans les faits il y en a au moins
ils vont rester vous dis ouais ce convoi
accueillir vont rester mis en vente en
accueillir - se dit que la proportion de
succès vont être beaucoup plus graves
avec m'honore mais moins on est d'accord
il y en aura peut-être y en aura
sûrement moins au début mais au moins
ils vont rester
donc en fait il y en aurait plus qui va
rester que sous le régime libéral ou
avec la cac qui dit aux quarante mille
par année aucuns parlent français s'en
vont les trois ans après je veux leur
dire de s'en aller très bien parce que
des demandes de mandats vous savez gérer
val d'or en abitibi
je les ai tous vus en mauricie partout
même en gaspésie on a besoin oui de gens
qui restent transports c'est un c'est le
thème dont toulon par la mobilité
qu'est-ce que vous prioriser parce que
l'outaouais à ses projets le train à
gatineau il ya l'autoroute 5 ans
l'autoroute 30 à montréal il ya le rêve
l'on veut étendre leur m à gauche à
droite comment vous prioriser tous ces
troisièmes lignes à québec tramway à
québec comment vous de prioriser qu'est
ce qui est important de faire bombe à
d'abord cessé réduire la congestion et
choisir des projets qui sont pas
pharaonique mais dont on sait que lorsqu
on les multiplie ça réduit la congestion
nos hauts lieux du renne qui est un
projet on avec le même argent
on a 28 projets différents dans la
région de montréal sur des voies
existantes avec des technologies
existantes dont seront six à avoir
réduit de 10% la congestion de 10% à la
congestion un oui l'outaouais un projet
de train léger sur rail de 1,2 milliard
on n'a pas encore le chiffre c'est très
bien à québec et intra moins de 3
milliards c'est très bien troisième bien
vous n'êtes pas les mois jugé pas de je
pense que ça va augmenter la congestion
mais j'attends l'étude d'opportunité
contrairement à monsieur couillard
monsieur legault qu'ils n'ont pas besoin
d'études de conception à le voir aller
encore plus values veux pisser coûte que
coûte
moi premier ministre patrice jamet je
veux dire que je vais faire quelque
chose coûte que coûte parce que la bonne
gestion des fonds publics c'est de
toujours voir le bon rapport
qualité-prix leur m
vous continuez à vouloir changer la
donne même si le 1er octobre ce sera 10
est déjà lancé tout ça parce c'est à
dire lorraine ne fonctionnera pas aux
premières nobles 60% des travaux du rem
se font vers la rive-sud et c'est un
segment que nous voulons utiliser leur
haine dans d'autres endroits empêche de
réduire la congestion et leurs veaux
poser les vraies questions à ce moment
là maintenant ce qui est important c'est
que y'a de la fluidité
je vous donne un exemple concret sur
l'a30 sur la rive-sud eux c'est clair
c'est presque un stationnement dans les
deux sens cette plusieurs années que les
gens locaux demandent au moins utilisons
les accotements une pour faire passer
des autobus
le mtq leur dire on peut port il ya
douze lampadaires qu'on devrait dès
qu'on devrait déplacer
j'ai écouté moi je connais quelqu'un de
nico des requins marteaux piqueurs y est
disponible on va les tasses et les
lampadaires parce qu'on a défendu le non
plus mais il ya des actions à prendre
rapidement pour la fluidité dans la peau
a utilisé plus après la pause on faire
des questions en rafale vont aborder
tous les sujets qui vous intéressent et
qui intéresse les téléspectateurs je
reviens sur l'esprit de la campagne
est ce que vous êtes papa que ça dérape
vous êtes capable au su des tracés mort
d'un puits même méchant à la limite des
fois tranchant tranches ont beau dire
quand je prends champ d'action s'étend
sur trancher est ce que vous vous dites
attention jean-françois je suis mon pire
ennemi
je dois il faut tenter que cette
campagne se fasse quand même de façon
correcte bien sûr qu on se frappe mais
de façon corée absolument moi je pense
qu'il faut dire des vérités vos ordis
vérité
il faut pas la langue de bois ça ne
m'intéresse pas ce songe pas capable je
serais même pas de m'entraîner mais il
faut être à la hauteur de les attentes
des québécois d'être le plus positif
possible dans un dans un processus car
d1 de comparaison donc vous vous
rappelez sur le matin par g maintenant
la prévision
jean françois lisée après la pose des
questions à la fin octobre est-ce que
construire le centre vidéotron avec
essentiellement uniquement de l'argent
public trading
[Musique]
jean françois lisée les questions en
rafale première est ce possible de
promettre aux québécois un temps
d'attentes maximale pour avant de voir
un médecin d'urgence si oui combien tu
as moi je me méfie énormément de ça
parce que ce qu'il faut organiser c'est
que les gens aillent pas aux urgences
c'est ça qui va marcher c'est ça qu'on
prendrait dit non je dis je veux pas
m'avancer la crédibilité de ses
propositions la plus d'argent de
subventions pour l'achat d'une auto
électrique ses 8000 $ au québec 13
milles en ontario vous d'accord plus
d'argent il faudrait qu'on ait assez de
bornes de recharge rapide et on en a pas
une question qu'on se pose quel est le
meilleur on utilise la même utilisation
de ces fonds là pour faire le changement
électrique qu'est ce qu'il faut pas plus
mettre plus d'argent dans leurs aises
l'explication des autobus par exemple
peut-être art a peut-être avoir hérité
autobus électriques très bien d'accord
pour donner de l'argent public un
nouveau stade de baseball à mourir très
peu il faudrait que tu estimant qu'une
brique
oui s'il faut construire tout le mur non
est-ce que construire le centre
vidéotron avec essentiellement
uniquement de l'argent public a été une
erreur
demandez à jean charest je vous le
demande à vous vous avez des réponses
courtes très bien donc les pauvres
le pauvre dans un musée conçu un vieux
débat est ce que vous seriez main dans
la main avec justin trudeau pour
défendre les intérêts des travailleurs
canadiens et donc québécois devant les
attaques de d'angle bas j'ai voulu faire
la semaine dernière mais jodie qui serai
flexible sur un point les intérêts du
québec sur le lait ce que son ministre
confirmé alors il est prêt à être fermes
pour le reste du canada mais faible sur
le lait alors si c'est ça c'est non pas
main dans la main ben je veux bien jouer
sa main à lui mais a dit lundi qu'il va
ils vont nous lâcher nous pour protéger
aurait dû qu'à la concession pour la
gestion de l'offre
aucune concession avec moi premier
ministre assemblée nationale ne vaut
ratifié aucun accord international qui
augment et klein les importations de
lait quotas d'importation de lait c'est
parce que monsieur charest
monsieur
gaudy est-ce qu'on devrait limiter le
mandat d'un premier ministre au québec à
deux demandeurs merci bonsoir c'est très
difficile dans les temps modernes
d'avoir plus que deux mandats au québec
quand je pense que déjà la population
s'en occupe
parité obligatoire au conseil des
ministres moi j'ai ouï obligatoires
ouais caucus voilà c'est plus compliqué
ces choses qu'on contrôle pas
on travaille très fort pour 115 dollars
salaire minimum ou quatrième semaine de
vacances bon là on en demande beaucoup à
nos pme à plus de 70% nos entreprises
sont des pme
nous on est pour la troisième semaine de
vacances bien sûr on est pour des jours
de congés mobiles pour des questions de
santé ou d'enfance travaillons sur le
salaire minimum de façon graduelle
jusqu'à la fin trait de 2022 en aidant
les entreprises qui ont des difficultés
avec leur coup de main des réponses les
plus courts prix de l'essence est ce que
le gouvernement du québec est impuissant
devant ces fluctuations
et ce qui ressemble des fois de la
concertation jeter tous les mardis ou
mercredis ça monte de 10 m à montréal
c'est clair que il a choisi d'être
impuissant nous nous proposons que
l'office de protection du consommateur
se donne des moyens d' enquêtes et de
sanction parce que le bureau de la
concurrence du canada qui devrait s'en
occupe et en occupant
est-ce que vous démissionnez jean
françois lisée si vous n'êtes pas élu
premier ministre
ou est ce que vous faites vous êtes élu
dans heureusement votre mandat au
complet achevé mon band au complet c'est
certain ce que vous allez gagner oui je
vais gagner parce qu'on est des vrais
parce que ce qu'on propose
on le croit on le sait les gens qui sont
avec nous cherche pas le parti qui va
les faire élire selon le dernier sondage
il se cherche le parti qui représente
leur conviction jean françois lisée
bonne chance
on se retrouve donc le 13 septembre un
débat je crois c'est bien d'y participer
[Musique]